le cycle de l'eau commence dans les
océans chauffé par le soleil l'eau
s'évapore elle se condense en nuage
puis se déverse en pluie ou encore en
neige
elle infiltre alors les sols où elle
forme d'immenses réserves d'eau sous
terre
[Musique]
mais l'eau coule aussi en surface elle
rejoint les rivières et les fleuves
une partie sera prélevée par les hommes
le reste regagnera les océans et ainsi
de suite c'est ce cycle à l'infini qui
nous fournit de l'eau douce
[Musique]
mais pour capter toute cette eau que
nous offre la nature et la boire au
robinet il a fallu un deuxième miracle
un miracle humain cette fois
car en france pendant longtemps quand on
voulait de l'eau il fallait aller la
chercher soi-même au puy pour la
rapporter à la maison
en 1850 napoléon iii confie au baron
haussmann une mission de taille
moderniser paris ce dernier imagine
alors des circuits pour acheminer l'eau
depuis la source est un réseau d'égouts
moderne
trois ans plus tard l'empereur décide
d'apporter l'eau courante à tous les
français devant l'ampleur de la tâche il
délègue les travaux à une société privée
créée pour l'occasion la compagnie
générale des eaux devenue depuis veolia
à cette époque n'est aussi l'autre
grande compagnie française la lyonnaise
des eaux
des travaux titanesques
achevé il n'y a pas si longtemps
puisant sa depuis ce matin de l'eau
potable alors le village a fêté
l'événement comme il se doit le village
a fêté l'autre cette commune de franche
comté et la dernière à être relié au
réseau c'était il y à 30 ans à peine
tous les français ont enfin l'eau
courante au robinet
[Musique]
avec 900 mille kilomètres de
canalisations nous avons donc la chance
d'avoir en france l'un des réseaux les
plus performants au monde
un réseau qui puisent l'eau dans les
nappes souterraines pour les deux tiers
et dans les rivières pour un tiers mais
avant d'être distribuée à notre robinet
l'on va devoir passer par une usine très
spécial un centre qui valent à traiter
pour la rendre potable un nouvel exploit
qui va mobiliser tout le génie humain
[Musique]
la marne une rivière parmi tant d'autres
en france
c'est bien cette eau trouble qui est
directement prélevé dans la rivière et
qui tout au bout de ce canal couvert va
atterrir au coeur d'une immense machine
à laver ou elle sera purifié
l'eau contient toutes sortes de
d'impuretés des essentiellement de
l'argile en suspension des matières
organiques mais aussi des virus des
bactéries
toutes sortes de produits que l'on ne
peut pas voir qu'ils sont aussi très
très dangereux donc tout ça il va
falloir effectivement les mines et ça
fait partie du processus de
potabilisation et pour que cette eau
redevienne bonne à boire on va donc
devoir employer les grands moyens
elle a combien des piscines comme ça il
y en a 12 ans l'eau va décanter en
passant d'un bassin à l'autre et à
chacun son rôle par exemple ces bacs
contiennent de films billes d'argile qui
retiennent les impuretés visible
dans les suivants c'est un fait un ami
de sable qui va jouer le rôle de filtre
naturel
mais il reste encore une menace
invisible à l'oeil nu et ce sont ces
gros cylindre appeler aux honneurs
qu'ils vont s'en charger
et vous allez pouvoir voir ici en fait
le traitement à l'ozone on voit
parfaitement
toutes ces petites bulles à que vous
voyez c'est de l'ozone l'ozone est en
occident très puissant qui va tuer tout
ce qui est virus tout ce qui va kerry en
fait le jeune et efficace sur tous les
nuisibles microscopiques qui sont
contenus dans l'eau à l'issue de tout ce
processus l'eau et dépolluer bonne a
distribuée au robinet
pour s'en assurer l'eau va tout de même
passé un dernier test un test plutôt
surprenante sarah octobre on est
douteuse d'eau chaque jour elle déguste
la production de l'usiné pour y détecter
d'éventuelles anomalies un rôle clé car
aucune machine ne peut égaler la
précision des papilles humaine
alors pour préserver ses papilles sarah
a interdiction de fumer de boire du café
ou de manger épicé
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez voir comme
sensation quand il ya un problème de
temps en temps si on a un problème
d'ozone en fin de compte on va on va
goûter sa tour et s'il ya vraiment un
problème là par contre on sentira un
mouvement d'arrêt et qu'est ce qui se
passe nous synthèse vous demanderais
nouveau need attention pour arrêter la
dissolution des recettes santé quoi vous
là dessus et pour moi c'est un goût
neutre c'est ce qu'on appelle un goût
neutre c'est-à-dire qu'elle est bonne à
boire